hello everyone my name is musan hang
i'm a researcher from professor brass
group at mit department of chemical
engineering
thank you for providing me this chance
to present about my research at lab
roots bioprocessing 2021
today i'll present about model-based
control for continuous bond activation
of biopharmaceuticals
to begin with brief introduction of
biopharmaceuticals
they are products derived from
biological organism for treating or
preventing diseases
the global sales of our pharmaceuticals
have continuously increased for many
years
they are projected to reach about 500
billion dollars by 2026.
percentage of biopharmaceuticals
industrial pipeline have also
continuously
increased resulting in hundreds of
approved products on the market
and over 8 000 medicines and clinical
development
the figure in this slide shows a process
for a diagram for a typical platform
used for producing monoclonal antibodies
which are the highest selling class of
pharmaceuticals
the traditional biopharmaceutical
manufacturing consists of a similar
sequence of batching operations
that are divided into upstream and
downstream
the offstream unit operations include
cell culture with a series of batch
bioreactors for protein expression
and harvest steps for removing cells and
cell debris
which are decentrification and
filtration in this case
the downstream consists of purification
with multiple steps
of chromatography infiltration and
difficultration
there are several trends in
biopharmaceutical manufacturing
providing important roles for process
system engineering
first the growth of biologics increase
interest in applying process analytical
technology
p-a-t p-a-t is a system of analyzing
manufacturing
through online measurements of critical
quality attributes
to ensure the final product quality
online measurements provide much more
data on the multi-variable interactions
and dynamics
depending on the process understanding
these data have been used to construct
first principles
and database models for each of the
union operations
another trend is a transition of many
processes from batch to continuous
operation
this is for reducing manufacturing costs
and increasing productivity and quality
however the continuous manufacturing
processes
also provide new process control
problems
continuous processes have to handle the
propagation of impurities and other
disturbances
caused by the tight integration of
continuous union operations
another area of interest is the
invention of these designs for protein
separations
currently the dominant method is picked
by chromatography
due to its high resolution but this
method is costly for high-dose
pharmaceuticals
so non-chromatography surfacing methods
are becoming more attractive
as modern bioreactors are achieving
higher productivity
and crystallization is one of the more
promising proposed technology
this will be a major shift in
biopharmaceutical manufacturing
it will involve new processes to be
controlled
these trends ultimately lead by
manufacturing to digital manufacturing
digital manufacturing is an integrated
approach to manufacturing
that is centered around the computer
system and again
visual manufacturing is intense by using
modern systems engineering tools
first modeling and stimulation provides
increased mechanistic fidelity and
better empirical approaches
and can be applied real time for
automated decision making
process optimization can be also applied
real time
for drug and patient specific
manufacturing
and high fidelity model based
optimization can reduce experimental
costs
systems engineering also provides tools
for dealing with process uncertainty and
model-based optimal control
these results in fully automated systems
minimizing errors caused by the human
operators
moreover synergy between these tools
enhances
impact to the digital manufacturer
the figure on this side shows the
knowledge pyramid for model-based
decision-making
higher layers in the pyramid correspond
to greater knowledge
more informed and better reliability of
decision-making
and lower requirements for regulatory
oversight
because higher layers in the pyramid
rely more on knowledge and expertise
they are more generalizable and
extrapolatable
this makes these models applicable for
optimization and predictive scaling
on the other hand lower layers in the
pyramid rely more on data
and they are more specific and limited
to interpolation
so these models have limited predictive
power beyond the training
my research applies modern systems
engineering tools to develop advanced
biomanufacturing systems
for upstream i derive mechanistic
mathematical models
and optimal control methods for multiple
bioreactor configurations
including microbiota systems and certain
bioreactors
and for downstream i designed and
implemented laboratory systems
for protein crystallization and
continuous round activation
these systems were optimally designed
and control based on mechanistic
mathematical models
in addition i'm combining these
experimentally validated unit operations
into a plant-wide dynamic model this
integrated plant-wide model
will be able to map the raw materials
and operations
to the product quality attributes
anywhere in the system
in the interest of time for today's talk
i'll be presenting the work on the
continuous front activation system
as i have already mentioned before
continuous manufacturing of biologics
has been of interest to both academia
and industry
this is because of the manual advantages
such as reduced
cost and increased flexibility ease of
standardization and scale up
improvement in product quality however
the complexity of these processes
also bring control challenges and
opportunities
as you can see from the typical process
flow diagram
biologics derived from mammalian sources
have to undergo two
orthogonal virus removal processes this
is to remove the advantageous viruses
that may be present in the mass
resolving
and one common processing step is a
bachelor ph
hold to activate the envelope viruses
there are having several attempts to
adapt this technology to continuous
processing
which includes cyclic batch operation
continuous flow tubular reactors
and continuous flow column-based
reactors
however none of these continuous flow
reactors directly address the control
challenges with operating the system
for the system critical process
parameters are the operating ph
and the resonance time distribution you
determine the brown activation and also
the
impacts to product quality from
over-incubation or excessive ph
adjustment
to address these control challenges we
have constructed a low-cost
column-based continuous fund activation
system with off-the-shelf components
for operating ph we have implemented a
fast and accurate model-based feedback
control
to enable rapid startup and effective
disturbance rejection
for residence time distribution it was
estimated periodically during operation
through inverse tracer experiments then
this was used to estimate minimal
resonance time
which in turn was used to adjust feed
flooring
to look into the constructive system in
more detail the figure in this site
shows a process for a diagram
of the lab-scale continuous round
activation system
first to bring the fluid to a low ph
state a multi-channel peristaltic pump
was used
to pump input solution and acid to a
mixing unit and inline ph electrode
the mixed stream then flowed into a
column packed with inner glass
to incubate low p solution for
sufficient time for ground activation
an injection system was used to
periodically inject uv
transparent solution into the flow
stream
uv absorbent sensors were placed at the
column inlet and outlet to measure the
column current
the ph of the fluid leaving the column
was raised by mixing with base
using a second mixing unit and ph
electrode
in programmable logic controller was
used for low level control of the system
measurement data were received from the
ph and uv sensors
and the multi-channel precipitate pump
was connected for control actuation
the programmable logic controller was
also connected to computer
for data collection human motion
interface and online primary estimation
to start with modeling and control of ph
fast and accurate control is necessary
for rapid inactivation
while minimizing impact to product
quality
for this first principle speech model
was developed with reaction invariants
which are total concentration of
acid-base species
and total charge of remaining species
the basis of the ph model is from the
acid-base equilibria and total charge
balance
with reaction in variance and acid
dissociation constants
with the developed ph model gi
controller was implemented based on the
reaction in variants
which are now governed by the linear
dynamics
this accounts for the nonlinearities in
directly controlling ph
which is what we see from the typical
buffer titration groups
the uncertainty thing may exist in the
ph model where handled by maximum
operatory map estimation
this updates primary values based on
online measurement data
map estimation was formulated as a
constraint minimization problem
at each time point it takes into account
prior information on parameters
and current data to provide improved
estimates of the parameters
estimated model primaries were active
dissociation constants and also this
term alpha
sum alpha was used as a multiplicative
factor for correcting reaction and
variance
to deal with flow bias in the species
covariance of posterior distribution was
also updated at each time point with the
sensitivities of ph with respect to the
estimated parameters
this map estimation addresses
uncertainties due to natural or
unexpected variation
such as changing product and buffer
concentration during the operation
so this improves the performance and
robustness of the reaction invariant ph
controller
now let's move on to the low ph hold
column-based and activation of reactors
have to be designed
to simultaneously balance two competing
effects
of desired throughput and resistance
time distribution low pressure drop
and small dispersion
the design variables that we have for
these objectives
are column diameter and length particle
size and superficial velocities
in a column based design throughput is
scalable to the diameter of the column
so this variable is not independently
adjustable
having a fixed average resonance time
also relates
column length and superficial velocity
so we can consider column length to be
fixed as well
pressure drop from carbon cuisine
equation can be reduced to the given
formulation
in the similar way the standard
deviation of a dispersed peak
can be characterized as given
formulation from the correlation of the
dispersion coefficient
and we can see in both relationships
that the term superficial velocity over
particle size
only appears together in the
formulations
so we can conclude there is no way to
optimize our choice of particle size or
superficial velocity
to simultaneously reduce pressure drop
and dispersion
but in the interest of system
compactness a small particle size and
superficial velocity are preferred for
the system design
quantitative understanding of low ph
hold is important
to balance two competing effects of
brown activation and degrading product
quality
this comes in the form of resin time
distribution
which describes the time that a full
element spans within the system
by probability distribution function
the column was modeled as plug flow
reactor with axial dispersion
in series with a continuously stirred
tank reactor
with the respective resonance time
distributions shown in the gaming
formulations
plug full reactor with axial dispersion
describes the cylindrical chemical
reactor with continuous flow
and continuously searching a reactor
describes any non-ideality that might be
present in the actual call
then the concentration at the outlet of
the column can be calculated through the
convolution
of the concentration at inlet and the
residence time distribution of the
column
and again this time distribution of the
column
can be calculated through the
convolution of already model resistance
time distribution
of plug flow reactor with axial
dispersion and continuously third tank
reactor
the cumulative distribution function can
be also simply computed
by integrating the resonance time
distribution over time
and this allows us to define the minimum
resonance time as a given formulation
term edit here is a small value
corresponding to the fraction of
material
leaving the column before the minimum
resonance time
this residence time distribution is
affected by several variables
such as reactor design geometry fouling
and inperformance
and these variables can be classified
into three different types
design variables are those that can be
controlled offline like reactor design
and geometry
disturbances are those that may vary
during operation
but cannot be effectively controlled
like valid
and manipulate variables are those that
can be controlled online
like input fluorites while design
variables have been exported quite
extensively by previous work
disturbance rejection has not been
discussed directly
actually disturbance rejection is even
more important
as these continuous reactors will be
operated for extended periods of time
in pilot or commercial scale
because residence time distribution is
infinite dimensional
it is impossible to completely reject
the disturbance with scalar manipulated
variables
so this has to be done on a
scalarization of resonance time
distribution
one of the scalarization is logarithmic
reduction value approach
where a non-linear mod is used to relate
with time distribution
to scalar logarithmic reduction value
this approach directly addresses the
critical quality attributes
but it relies on an accurate
inactivation model
however inactivation kinetics vary from
virus to virus
and they are uncertain during the
process development stage
so we avoided this uncertainty by
utilizing the minimum resonance time
approach
the refraction used for defining minimum
resonance time varies from 0.05 to 10 to
the minus 5 in the literature
and we use 0.05 fraction in this work
at the same time i would like to mention
that different fraction
or even logarithmic reduction value
approach can be trivially
implemented with the information of an
activation kinetics
we're controlling minimum resonance time
three components are needed
first means of measuring within time
distribution and minimal distance time
second feedback control algorithm for
adjusting flow rate
in response to minimum resonance and
measurement and lastly
means of actuating the fluid
first measuring minimum resonance time
directly using tracer experiments is
impossible
due to small fraction value and inline
sensor noise
to overcome this lack of observability
versus time distribution was estimated
as a parametric distribution
which then can be used to determine
manual resonance time
using the beard lambda law the
absorbance is directly proportional to
the concentration
so the primaries for residence time
distribution model can be calculated
through the given sum of squares
minimization problem
sufficient variability is necessary in
the absorbance
for the active primary estimation this
can be achieved through the normal
process variation in the system
but also safely through the periodic
injection of protein-free buffer
which has negligible uv absorbance
given the minimum resonance time
estimation a feedback control algorithm
was developed as given formulation
because peristaltic pump flow rate was
all are almost linear to computational
speed
the system can obtain the setpoint
within a single step after the resonance
time distribution measurement
any nonlinearities or disturbances such
as tubing stretch
are also addressed through this feedback
control
for experimental validation of the
described system we have conducted
experiments to demonstrate the
controller performance
these experiments were planned to ensure
that the solution ph is correctly low to
the target ph for bond activation
solution residence time is accurately
and precisely controlled
and the solution ph is correctly erased
back to the target ph
for further downstream unit operations
the first experiment was planned to
demonstrate that the system is capable
of tracking ph
and minimal resistance and separates
second experiment was planned to
demonstrate that the system is capable
of suppressing ph disturbances
this was done by changing to a different
buffer for ph control
without updating the initial parameter
values
last experiment was planned to
demonstrate that the system is capable
of suppressing residence time
disturbances
this was done by using a bypass line to
suddenly decrease the active volume in
the system
for these controller validation
experiments 0.1 molar sodium hydroxide
was used as the test input solution
with one percent acetone used as a
tracer for the absorbance measurements
one molar phosphoric acid was used for
the acid stream
and one molar sodium hydroxide was used
for the baseline
the ionized water was used as a low
absorbent injection solution for the
resonance time distribution estimation
plus on this slide showed experimental
results for tracking ph separates
but on the top shows flow rates
determined by the ph controller
and plot on the bottom shows ph
measurements with set points shown as
flash dash lines
during the experiment the set point for
first mixing unit was changed from 3 to
4 at 60 minutes
and reverted to 3 at 120 minutes
gauge set point for second mixing unit
was also changed from 7 to 8
180 minutes and reverted to 7 at 240
minutes
we can see from these spots that the
setpoint tracking was achieved
with fast and accurate response and no
instagram
plus on this slide showed experimental
results for tracking minimum
residence time separates fast from the
top
show flow rate determined by the minimum
resonance time controller
observance measurements at the internet
and outlet of the column
and estimating minimal resonance time
the set points shown as fact dash lines
during the experiment the nmrs time
resistance time set point was changed
from 240 seconds to 300 seconds 180
minutes
and reverted to 240 seconds at 360
minutes
first we can see from the second part
that the resin time distribution model
with estimated primers
will describe the concentration at the
outlet
also we can see from the bottom part
that the set point tracking was achieved
within single step after the resonance
time distribution estimation
moving on to the next validation
experiment disturbance rejection was
tested for ph control by changing the
buffer concentration of the acid stream
from phosphoric acid to citric acid this
was done with a mole still being
initialized with the acid dissociation
constants of phosphoric acid
so the mole is initially not aware of
the buffer change in the answer stream
plus on this slide showed experimental
results for the disturbance rejection of
ph controller
from the top plus show flow rate
determined by the piece controller
p measurements with set points shown as
black dashed lines
and the estimated primary values of acid
dissociation constants
with true values for citric acids shown
as black dash lines we can see from the
second part that the setpoint tracking
was again achieved
with fast and accurate response and no
instability
even with the introduced disturbance we
can also see from the bottom plot
that the map estimation algorithm
quickly estimated the acid dissociation
constants of citric
acid truly from the pitch measurements
in the first few minutes
for the last validation experiment
disturbance rejection was tested for the
minimum resonance time control
by adding an additional length of tubing
in series with the column
while the system is in normal operation
tube clamps were used to remove this
additional length of tubing in the flow
path
as shown in this process for gathering
this effectively led to suddenly
decreasing the active volume through the
column
and therefore suddenly decreasing the
resonance time in the system
the plots in this slide showed
experimental results for disturbance
rejection of minimal resonance time
controller
which vertical line shows the time and
the length of the cube was decreased
with a tube clamped
we can see from the second part that the
mall correctly predicted the output of
each water injection
even after when the sudden disturbance
was introduced into the system
we can see from the bottom part that the
minimum resonance time measurement
correctly identifies the following
change in the system recent time
then the controller adjusts the pump
speed accordingly
and restore the original residence time
set point again in a single step
to conclude in this work we constructed
a low-cost
column-based continuous product equation
system with off-the-shelf components
and controller validation experiments
demonstrated
that ph and minimum residence time
segwaying tracking
and also disturbance rejection are
achieved with fast and accurate response
and no instability
overall this work provided tools for the
design and operation of continuous file
activation systems
in service of increasing productivity
improving product quality
enhancing patient safety
with that i would like to acknowledge my
co-workers listed here
and also the funding source u.s food and
drug administration
and thank you all for your attention